oh for sure I pay out the ass for gas
dude mmm it's insane
IIIi mean I came here for gas anymore
that's why I wanna get a scooter are you
know about the razor scooter the one
that you push the cue have you seen me
jump off a curb with it it's pretty fire
but I feel like if you if you're an
adult and you ride a scooter then know
also what you do is you ask taller men
if they have games on their phone for
sure what kind of games even if I'm a
mime yeah you got Tetris on your phone
that's exactly what I was it when I was
in college I was thinking I was at
Northridge and people would always ride
scooters around to class and in my head
I would be like why why because I'm
walking right next to you I not I've
never seen a scooter go at distance I
walk a dog and it's like a razor scooter
and I'm gonna if it's a skateboard
that's one thing but like that's those
are kind of quiet if it's a bike I get
it but a scooter have you seen a razor
scooter go downhill yeah have you seen
me roll down a hill take somewhere the
ugliest things I've ever done when I was
in a UCI they should live it next to you
for sure had a scooter oh student donors
so this dude named peter dinh he had a
scoot razor scooter which I thought was
the stupidest thing ever but I was late
a couple of times to go to my [ __ ]
was it called or a [ __ ] final and the
bus just wasn't gonna come in time it
was like every 10 minutes or so I was
just like okay that's good I got you on
this course I borrowed a scooter and a
270-pound man on a scooter just flying
down the hill be here and I made it in
time
oh yeah then when you walked up the hill
you just threw the scooter away cuz that
doesn't do me any good back for sure I
was pretty [ __ ] fast fell dude I
remember I didn't learn how to when I
was like I think I didn't learn how to
ride a bike tells like 13o insane I know
just don't looking like that okay that's
real ways I didn't learn how to ride a
bike tell us 13 because the reason why I
know this is because my grandma got me a
scooter for my 13th birthday and that's
how I learned how to ride a bike do what
went on what yeah me learning how to
like balance on a scooter
like that to riding a bike so the theme
of this guy's bike is you know
cross-training is very important I feel
like when I when I would write when I
was riding that scooter just to get to
my class I swear to god it was just like
I don't like [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ]
virgin just rolled down so fast guys
only seen one dick in his life that's
this I don't even know why I rush to go
to that classes I failed it either way
I myzel just not a showed up damn
difference yeah I don't know why I don't
know why it like I did give a [ __ ] about
academia but I would always rush to
class if I was late for a test as I
brought you didn't study you're gonna
fail either way to show up late
it doesn't matter dude that's just your
morals your moral compass here's a good
guy dude you know I'd always just try to
cheat yeah usually worked not me I
always got caught do really yeah I'm not
very good she got caught cheating yeah
are you willing high school not in
college college it was he if you got
caught cheating is a big deal I was so
good at cheating since it was insane
like the only time I got caught cheating
was when I was a freshman and I tried to
BS this book report on it was like front
like an anthropology class or some [ __ ]
and the guy was laughing and he asked me
to come up to him I was like I want you
to see who wrote this book look it was
the professor's name he goes you
literally did not read this book all
that
Touche I'll give you another day to do
it
we do it what a scam that guy was and he
probably made you guys buy it all for
sure and he just made a bunch of money
off dude oh I had a film history
professor in college I think PCC and
this dude made us buy his brandy book
because all his quizzes had to be on the
online portion what and this book was I
think like $180 a film history book for
$180 makes no so forget about it
traditional education is so [ __ ]
expensive nonsense yeah look at that
you'd learn nothing from it you're the
dumbest person I know history I know a
lot tell me something about film history
right now it'll blow my [ __ ] mind
Nick what era whatever what era would
you want to learn about it
what era yeah the era right now I did
that class didn't go that far
okay 30 years ago 400 blows is a French
black-and-white film about a young man
see I'm doing what Drake did the thing
about the chief so poetic about how yeah
I'm not gonna even try to be us that
because I never went to class and I
failed I think I failed the midterm but
I passed class here's some funny [ __ ]
this is how much I hate school we were
you know for one of my businesses we're
learning how to make coffee like
espresso because we're using that in our
latte and then the first thing that we
do they gave us this sheet of all the
information and I have such bad habits
of school they're like okay well first
of all everybody was just supposed to
put their name on the paper so they just
know whose paper it is so we lose it and
the first thing I did I look over to see
what they're writing and it's like dude
it's just your name you write your own
[ __ ] name you dumbass and they
started writing her and are you reading
her name on your [ __ ] paper bro yeah
you says you are a bad student bad
habits dude I [ __ ] hate a school man
but I still Thursday as an adult I get
nightmares of me being late for school
yeah oh I do too I do too I get those
same dreams hate that number one time I
was pull it was like my senior year at
Northridge and I just was like dude I'm
[ __ ] I hate this place I want to get
out of here hated school I one time I
had a drive all the way to Northridge
from Pasadena to do a final where I had
a juggle that was my final what I had to
juggle
I had a juggle I failed miserably I mean
what kind of school what kind of it was
good for motor development so learning
how to - you're the clown college is
what I'm saying right no I didn't do
this College you have had your red nose
minefield anyways the second part so you
went to Clown College when you told that
story nobody the second part of the
final was me pulling out different
colored rats at a month up but you
failed because there was just only white
rags
rags and then like a dildo attached and
I was like no but yeah I was I was
sitting in I was in the left turn lane
and in my head I was like dude like I
gotta get out of school like what am I
doing here I was like I need a sign like
what the [ __ ] like I shouldn't be in
school right now and then I get
rear-ended boom like oh [ __ ] I got
pulled over and in my head I'm like dude
if that's not a sign I don't know what
is but actually going to school was for
me at least towards the end once I
finished it I was like okay I'm kind of
glad I let you graduate I didn't
graduate
yeah well for you know I just have you
know two letters by my name that slowly
stands for [ __ ] I did not graduate
college at all
it was okay college sucks dude oh for
sure sucked I hated it well you have to
you have to really know what you want
and you didn't feel like you knew what
you wanted to do if I could go back in
time I wish that I don't think I
regretted going to college I think that
I regretted not [ __ ] around more in
college hmm
like really phoning it in yeah cuz I
just didn't do [ __ ] I stayed in my in my
apartment or just got drunk that's it by
yourself
yeah but then like that was when I went
out when that drunk by myself you stupid
son of a [ __ ]
oh man but it was like because like when
I was in Riverside I don't want to be
there yeah and I think I said a tough
place to [ __ ] my sister went there you
UCR is the armpit of Southern California
and there are for sure prostitutes on
campus just and they're called students
and teachers and [ __ ] hated the
University of California Riverside I
heard I got a lot better after they took
my tuition but now it's just they
actually built some decent [ __ ] there
but then Applebee's hated it dude
[ __ ] hated it and then I started
having a better college experience after
I left there I went to Community College
cuz you know you just I'm just like well
[ __ ] its Community College by the way
better just because I don't know like I
just I think I started understanding
like how the education system worked
really late in life like dwara
how to be a better student like how to
really play the game yeah did you know
there's something called the syllabus
yeah what is that they teach this
curriculum they tell you the clueless
but it's gonna be I had no idea
right so that's what that
is Isis sit in class and fidget so much
you see do you think me sitting in this
is like bad fidgeting Isis sit in class
and literally just be like this all
class and not do a [ __ ] thing I tap
on the [ __ ] I tap on the table I'd
flip papers around and I dude I hated
being in class because there were some
teachers I would just sit behind the
desk and just read just say nothing they
would just read they would just read to
us that's [ __ ] and we're in college and
we're paying this is like a core
curricular Club like this is a core
class for your major it is crazy and
this dude he would talked about how he
was tenured and he couldn't get fired he
said that off the top first off I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah literally no power
points nothing just he would just he
would actually read that that was what
it was he would read the power points
not put it up but read it off the piece
of paper and then give it to us at the
end of class oh my god dude I'd [ __ ]
blow my process how does that carry my
citation I would it was such a waste of
time Community College one of the
hardest things about Community College
was specifically when there were certain
students like they thought that they
were so much better than the professor's
there that was just kid I used to call I
used to call him actually his mother
[ __ ]
every [ __ ] time the professor has
sent to say something right you know
he's been like well actually well
actually this is annoying it was like an
English Lit class it was something that
I needed to take the transfer over to
like a university this is after I
dropped out of Riverside and I and I
went to Community College to go back to
Sac State but he was just always
interrupts the professor as he's TV he
goes well actually the information is
Deming and like you could tell the
professor's getting [ __ ] irritated
dude he's like dude just let me teach
the [ __ ] lesson
nobody cares he goes well you know in
Mesopotamia when it came to literature
it's like bro I will [ __ ] slit your
throat shut the [ __ ] up
so I finally one day I [ __ ] slurs throat
I [ __ ] snap because I was
because we're just fighting we're just
trying to get through to the class right
like I paid for this and I just need him
to finish up the lesson so we know what
they study for this kid just would not
stop rambling you could tell like the
professor's rolling his eyes and I just
looked at the guys like dude shut the
[ __ ] up whole class has got [ __ ]
quiet I was like bro I'm not paying
money to hear you [ __ ] talk so shut
the [ __ ] up I was like if you say one
more [ __ ] thing i'm just gonna slap
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
you know everybody's just cracking up in
the class because they're so irritated
yeah everyone's like yeah for sure yes
and then the professor goes [ __ ]
thank you he goes if you interrupt me
what he just goes off he's like [ __ ] it
we're all going all in yeah start going
off on this student just like dude that
day David's never got his dick sucked
more in one day that's that professor
that dude could suck
[Laughter]